mes chers collègues avec
mon coprésident Cyril Lisa cibil nous
débutons un cycle d'audition par lamex
afin que celle-ci poursuive sa mission
de contrôle et de suivi de différents
sujets ayant un lien direct avec les
lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale et en l'espèce nous sommes ravis
d'accueillir pierre loubra président du
Conseil d'orientation des retraites dont
les travaux je dois le dire avaient
largement contribué à nourrir alimenter
nos débats au cours de l'examen
parlementaire de la réforme des
retraites elle-même portée par un projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale
rectificatif j'en profite pour dire que
les rapports que rendent le Conseil tout
comme les journées d'études qui
l'organisent en vue d'intégrer les
résultats de la recherche académique et
des organismes statistiques dans les
réflexions globales sur notre système de
retraite constitue un éclairage toujours
précieux pour les parlementaires que
nous sommes alors je propose de rentrer
dans le cœur du sujet
après la publication du 10e rapport du
corps en juin 2023 la presse a relayé le
message que selon le dernier rapport du
corps la réforme des retraites ne
permettra pas de ramener les régimes à
l'équilibre à l'horizon 2030 dans la
foulée Bruno Le Maire le ministre de
l'Économie a affirmé prendre ses
nouvelles prévisions avec prudence
reprochant à l'instant s'indépendante de
modifier ses évaluations tous les six
mois
d'ailleurs le communiqué du corps que
vous avez publié le 22 juin mentionne
que je cite plusieurs déclarations vise
à remettre en cause la constance et la
qualité des travaux du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites d'où ma
première question et le premier
éclairage qui justifie votre présence
vous l'avez mentionné dans votre
communiqué y a-t-il mais je connais la
réponse mais faites-nous la
démonstration une révision substantielle
entre les projections de 2022 et de 2023
du Conseil d'orientation des retraites
quels sont les écarts de dépenses entre
les projections de 2023 et des
projections de 2022 et de manière
symétrique quelles sont les écarts des
projections des ressources entre 2023 et
2022 enfin quels sont les écarts de sols
entre les deux exercices ma deuxième
question sera le constat d'une
diminution des dépenses en proportion du
PIB est-il toujours valable c'était un
des éléments de votre rapport de
d'octobre l'année dernière et surtout
quel est l'effet de la réforme sur cette
sur cette tendance dans notre bonne
information avez-vous calculé l'effet
net consolidé sur les comptes publics
tout a pu
du recul de l'âge légal de 62 à 64 ans à
l'horizon 2030 quelles sont les
principaux facteurs qui empêchent les
comptes du système de retraite d'être à
l'équilibre en 2013 et en particulier
vous pouvez vous revenir sur l'évolution
des recettes projetées entre 2030 et
2070 et quel mécanisme identifiez-vous
identifiez-vous à cette à cet égard je
livre d'un bloc les questions que pour
éviter de les reposer et permettre aux
députés présents de pouvoir compléter de
manière plus spécifique vous pouvez vous
revenir sur l'impact sur l'EGI
l'équilibre du régime des retraites de
l'évolution des traitements des
fonctionnaires parce que c'était un des
sujets qu'il y avait animé le débat et
j'ajouterai une dernière une dernière
question qu'est-il arrivé à la
Convention effort constante de l'État
pourquoi avons-nous le sentiment qu'elle
est reléguée d'une certaine manière au
second plan voilà quelques-uns des
points que nous souhaitons aborder dans
cette dans cette audition et si on a le
temps on serait aussi heureux de pouvoir
pouvoir puisque vous venez d'être
missionné par le gouvernement pour
réfléchir à l'évolution des droits
familiaux de retraite dans notre dans
notre système
nous indiquer parce que ça nous
intéresse et même envisager un temps ce
sujet comme un des sujets de travail de
la Mecque et comme nous savions que le
gouvernement allait vomit
préféré attendre vos conclusions nous
indiquer d'ores déjà la méthode que vous
comptez employer pour mener à bien cette
mission et et les points sur lesquels
vous comptez travailler en priorité
voilà je termine en réduisant tout
l'attachement que nous avons à être
éclairé par les travaux utiles de cet
instance indépendant indépendante dont
tous les cas personnellement je
considère qu'elle est particulièrement
précieuse dans le débat public
l'initiative ce matin c'est pas le
rapporteur de la branche veillée ce qui
intervient mais bien le coup président
d'un mecs
pour nous il s'agit de s'intéresser à il
ne s'agit pas de s'intéresser à la
construction du futur belfs nous le
ferons l'automne mais c'est plutôt
d'évaluer les mesures retraites
examinez par l'Assemblée lors du dernier
PVC rectificatif c'est le rôle de
l'index et d'interroger le dernier
rapport que le corps a produit celui des
juin 2023 car vous le savez beaucoup de
parlementaires ont trouvé dans votre
rapport dans l'année dernière septembre
2022 des arguments en faveur ou en
défaveur de cette réforme tout le monde
pouvait trouver
argument dans votre rapport ce qui est
un petit peu déconcerté pas mal de monde
il y a deux choses c'est vrai que il y a
les écrits c'est-à-dire il y a les
rapports et puis il y a les écrits
étaient les rapports et puis après
effectivement il y a ce que vous avez pu
dire et je reviendrai dessus dans le
sens où entre guillemets vous vous êtes
exprimé il faudrait que je retrouve la
phrase
exacte que vous avez dit
pour nous ça nous interroge et donc la
question c'est pourquoi si effectivement
les choses à évolué entre le rapport de
juin
de septembre 2022 et celui de juin 2023
dans votre rapport vous aviez anticipé
la réforme
dans notre rapport de septembre 2022
mais est-ce que c'est effectivement les
mesures favorables qui ont été prises
vous soulignez nos derniers rapports
qu'effectivement quelle évolution des
retraites pour les femmes et pour les
petites retraites sont plutôt plus
favorables et ça serait eux ils gagnent
de la réforme est-ce que vous pouvez
nous confirmer et donc c'est ça je
trouve qui est intéressant c'est vrai
quand même temps le haut-commissaire aux
plans s'est interrogé
membre du groupe démocrate je suis
sensible à ses propos par rapport aux 30
milliards de surfinancement de l'État
pour pour équilibrer ces restes et ses
régimes et on aimerait effectivement
vous entendre par rapport par rapport à
ces défaits je vous remercie
merci de votre invitation je suis
accompagné par Frédéric nantier rebordi
qui est une membre du secrétaire général
du corps le secrétaire général du corps
aurait souhaité présent mais il
bénéficie de vacances simplement mérité
donc je vais essayer de répondre à votre
question mais si vous permettez je vais
commencer par vous vous rappeler
qu'est-ce que c'est que le corps en vous
rappelant sa composition donc vous voyez
qu'il y a des représentants du Parlement
quatre députés 47 heures donc pas tous
les groupes mais presque tous les
groupes il y a les représentants des
assurés sociaux et des employeurs donc
les représentants des employeurs le
Medef la CGPME le PA et puis toutes les
organisations syndicales de salariés il
y a les représentants de l'État toutes
les administrations concernées et puis
il y a des experts et représentants des
familles et des retraités je dis ça
parce que en voyant la composition du
corps vous comprenez qu'il y a au sein
du corps des gens qui sont et qui ont
été favorables à la réforme des
retraites et vous avez des gens qui sont
qui ont qui sont et qui ont été très
défavorables à la réforme des retraites
donc dans les rapports du corps vous ne
trouverez jamais une appréciation ou un
avis sur la réforme des retraites ce que
vous trouverez c'est des données et
normalement
voilà comme je me fais le porte-parole
des rapports du corps je
commente des données et je ne donne pas
d'avis sur la réforme des retraites
alors le problème c'est que bien souvent
quand je dis par exemple les dépenses de
retraite sont stables certains en
déduisent il n'y a pas lieu de faire une
réforme des retraites mais moi je n'ai
pas dit ça il y a une phrase qui est
rituelle dans notre synthèse que je vais
vous citer pour être pour être pour être
clair ou est-elle
elle est là on regarde ses projections
donc on regarde cette stabilité des
dépenses il ne revient pas au corps de
se positionner sur le choix du
dimensionnement du système de retraite
selon les préférences politiques et les
parfaitement légitime de défendre que ce
niveau de dépenses sont adéquat trop pas
assez élevés au regard de la richesse
nationale et des priorités assignées au
finances publiques donc nous on dit les
dépenses sont stables mais on dit tout
de suite ça ne veut pas dire que il ne
faut pas pour autant faire une réforme
des retraites ça veut pas dire qu'il en
faut faire une j'utilise cette image
régulièrement
un peu éculé si je viens chez vous et je
vous dis la température est stable c'est
une bonne nouvelle si on est à 19 si on
est à 5 degrés ou à 45 degrés c'est pas
une bonne nouvelle c'est pas au corps de
se prononcer sur est-ce que c'est le bon
niveau le corps dit aussi il y a un
déficit du système de retraite dans tous
les rapports du corps il est il est
indiqué qu'il y a un déficit du système
de retraite le corps d'un déduit pas il
y a un déficit du système de retraite
donc il faut repousser l'âge il dit il y
a s'il y a un déficit on peut repousser
l'âge on peut augmenter les cotisations
on peut
baisser le niveau des pensions et il
donne les les ordres de grandeur le
corps ne peut pas aller au-delà si
j'allais au-delà aussi le rapport du
corps à aller au-delà et bien
l'institution n'y survivrait pas puisque
bien évidemment au sein de cette
institution il y a des gens qui font
pour la réforme de retraite et le report
de là il y en a qui sont contre d'accord
alors vous me direz mais si le corps
ne fait que commenter des données à quoi
y faire déjà il établit des données et
ces données elles servent au débat on
peut dire c'est rien et je suis pré
obligé de reconnaître que ça ne réduit
pas la conflictualité autour de la
question des retraites néanmoins
rendez-vous compte de la situation si en
plus il n'y avait pas eu quelques
données de base pour sur lesquelles il y
avait un accord avant 2000
c'était une situation je sais pas si
vous vous rappelez mais il y avait un
rapport du CESU
rapporte lad et il y avait un rapport du
commissariat général plan on l'appelait
le rapport charpen ils aboutissaient à
des données complètement différentes
d'accord là les interprétations de ces
données et les prises de position
politique par rapport à ces données ont
été extrêmement divergentes et
conflictuelles de ça m'a pas échappé
néanmoins à la limite les données
étaient là et d'ailleurs le législateur
est parfaitement conscient que le corps
ne peut pas prendre position sur le
système de retraite et sur les réformes
à faire puisque il a prévu que un mois
après chaque rapport du corps il y a un
avis d'un comité de suivi des retraites
où il a il n'y a pas toutes ces parties
prenantes il y a des experts désignés
par le gouvernement qui donne la vie
c'est la vie vous allez vous allez le
recevoir au cours de au cours de cette
semaine et ces rituels chaque année
rapport du corps les données
et on peut pas aller plus jus de la
composition du corps sinon on fait tout
éclater et ensuite
avis du CSR donc le corps établit des
données
comment ces données essaie de les
expliquer ce que je vais essayer
aujourd'hui avec vous mais ne prend
jamais de position
sur sur le fond de ce qui doit être fait
si alors je sais qu'on va prêter des
propos bon par exemple
dernier audition le ministre monsieur du
soft a dit le président du corps a dit
il n'y a pas le feu au lac bon alors moi
tout de suite sur Google il retraite il
n'y a pas le feu au lac Laurent Berger
le 3 janvier c'est pas moi qui ai dit ça
je veux dire parce que moi je ne dis pas
ça je dis les dépenses de retraite sans
stable il y a une déficit et je vais
vous le je vais vous le redire mais je
ne dis je ne dis pas des des choses qui
engagent sur le sur les réformes à
conduire parce que je suis de
porte-parole de de
destitution pour lesquelles il y a des
promoteurs de la réforme des retraites
et il y a des opposants donc moi je moi
ma mission dans la République c'est de
faire fonctionner cette instance j'ai
essayé de remplir de remplir ma mission
et je sais que si je vais au-delà et
bien je ruine à l'institution et ce pour
que lequel était elle a été créée
c'est-à-dire créer des données voilà je
dis tout ça pour je pense que ça permet
de cadrer les choses
les choses au début alors après sur les
données bien évidemment on peut toujours
être meilleur dans la pédagogie dans la
présentation ce que nous avons choisi
cette année pour essayer d'améliorer la
présentation c'est au début de la
synthèse d'avoir ce tableau parce que je
vous parle d'éparence ressources soldes
et puis alors il y a des gens qui disent
oui il faut commencer par le sol et puis
après parler des dépenses d'autres
parler dépenses commencer par les
dépenses bon là on a dit sur un seul
graphe on essaie de donner la synthèse
de tout ce qu'il y a dans leur rapport
du corps sur la situation financière il
y a plein d'autres données sur la
situation sociale et ainsi de suite et
donc là vous avez le solde alors c'est
le rapport de cette année donc le sol de
cette année à gauche du
du slide et puis pour expliquer ce solde
Vous avez l'évolution des dépenses en
treplay et vous avez l'évolution des
ressources en très pointillés d'accord
donc là on voit clairement que en
2022 on a un solde positif de 0,2 qu'en
2030 on est à -02 et que en 2070 on est
à -08 je suis dans l'hypothèse qui a
choisi le gouvernement comme référence
pour la réforme des retraites c'est à
dire un scénario ou la productivité
augmente de 1% et le chômage est à 4 et
demi et donc pour expliquer ce solde
c'est bien évidemment un solde c'est des
dépenses des recettes et bien vous le
voyez on voit que les dépenses diminuent
sur le long terme par rapport au Bible
et que les ressources diminuent encore
plus et donc le solde il s'explique
voilà donc on peut à la fois dire sans
être en contradiction les dépenses de
retraite sont stables dans le PIB elles
ne dérape pas et on peut dire il y a un
déficit et il est durable je c'est ce
que je vais essayer de dire le le 19
janvier alors après que chacun se
saisisse d'un des membres de phrase je
le comprends tout à fait je suis pas
naïf voilà je connais le conflictualité
mais voilà ce que nous avons essayé de
faire alors est-ce qu'on a complètement
changé d'avis
d'une année sur l'autre donc là donc les
membres du corps qui ont été un peu
choqués par le fait que tout le monde
disait mais vous avez complètement
échangé de pied on a essayé de montrer
les projections 2022 et les projections
2023 dans le même format vous l'avez là
donc ça c'est les dépenses de retraite
d'un PIB alors vous voyez bien
évidemment qu'il y a des changements
heureusement il y a des changements
puisqu'il y a eu une réforme des
retraites et il y a eu des modifications
des des
prévisions macroéconomiques je vais
commenter ce changement vous voyez que
en gros ça dérape mon face c'est encore
plus stable cette année que ça ne
l'était l'année précédente réforme des
retraites mais de revenir sur sur les
écarts donc voilà ce qui était pour la
part des dépenses Alpes et puis même
chose pour le sol de du système de
retraite voilà ce que nous prévoyons
l'année précédente donc en 2021 on était
à zéro on prévoyait moins 0,4 en 2030
et je me situe sur la courbe orange -
0,8 en 2070 et bien là vous voyez que en
2022 on est à 0,2 on prévoit - 0,2 en
2030 et on sera encore à -08 en
2070 alors si on rentre dans le détail
de
de ces projections
alors une des difficultés que vous venez
d'évoquer monsieur le Président
mais qui ne tient pas au corps c'est que
en 2022 les prévisions
macroéconomique de court terme du
gouvernement qui sont celles qui sont
inscrites dans le programme de stabilité
intégré une réforme des retraites or
c'était une incohérence puisque le corps
projetait en 2022 les dépenses de
retraite à législation constante sans
réforme en 2022 la réforme n'existait
pas encore d'accord
nous nous sommes tournés vers le trésor
en leur disant
essayez de nous passer un scénario
macroéconomique épuré de la réforme
puisque eux la réintégrer dans leur
projection macroéconomique
ce n'était pas possible ils ne l'ont pas
souhaité je ne sais pas néanmoins j'ai
dû enfin j'ai dû assumer cette
incohérence en 2022 les projections
macroéconomiques intégrées une réforme
des retraites je ne sais d'ailleurs
toujours pas laquelle puisque en 2022
est-ce que c'est la réforme qui a été
votée en 2023 je n'en sais rien et ça
n'a jamais été
dit publiquement donc
voilà je ne sais rien donc et donc
intégrer une réforme des retraites et
moi la projections de dépenses nous les
faisons à législation constante c'était
une incohérence que le corps a subi et
que voilà mais mais franchement je n'y
peux rien donc vous ne pouvez pas en
comparant 2022 et 2023
mesurer l'effet de la réforme des
retraites puisqu'une partie notamment
les effets macroéconomiques sur le PIB
de la réforme de les retraites ou d'une
réforme des retraites était intégrée dès
2022 d'accord on dit ça clairement dans
le rapport de cette année on le disait
dans le rapport de l'année précédente
peut-être pas de manière assez exclusive
mais c'était le cas c'était une
difficulté que nous avons ressenti voilà
je Malaisie et je n'y peux bon ça c'est
le problème principal après bien
évidemment chaque année et même réforme
des retraites ou pas les prévisions
macroéconomiques de court terme changent
et cette année elles ont changé
en gros cette année on a beaucoup plus
de PIB prévu par le gouvernement que
l'année prochaine pas du PIB réel
d'accord l'an dernier la croissance du
PIB réel en
2023 prévu par le gouvernement c'était
1,4 c'est un nez maintenant ce n'est
plus que 1 en réel mais
nous faisons des projections en PIB
nominal et le prix du PIB le déflecteur
du PIB il y a un indice de prix à la
consommation il y a du prix du PIB
s'appelle le déflecteur du PIB il a été
très fortement augmenté par le par le
Trésor d'accord ça c'est des prévisions
macroéconomiques sur lequel je n'ai pas
compétence et je ne prétends pas les
avoir nous les prenons pour pour argent
comptant c'est d'ailleurs prévu dans la
loi que on projette le système de
retraite en s'appuyant sur les
prévisions du gouvernement bon donc ça
ça a un impact vous allez le voir très
important sur les résultats puisque ça
fait beaucoup plus de de richesse liées
à cette modification du déflecteur du
PIB donc je vais vous
parler des écarts en 2023 2022 mais avec
cette précaution il ne permettent pas de
lire directement l'effet de la réforme
des retraites parce que une réforme des
retraites était déjà intégrée dans les
projections macroéconomiques 2022 et
parce que mais ça c'est chaque année il
y a des modifications d'une année sur
l'autre
alors voilà la part des dépenses du
système dans le
pipe projeté en 2023 et en 2022 donc en
pointillés vous avez ce qui était
projeté en 2022 et en triple ce qui est
projeté en 203 d'accord et donc vous
voyez que il y a un décalage vers le bas
d'environ 0,5 points de PIB d'accord
alors je parle toujours en point de PIB
un point de PIB en 2022 le pipe c'est
2600 milliards donc un point de pipe
c'est 26 milliards 0 1 point de PIB
c'est 2,6 milliards d'accord je voulais
faire une traduction voilà donc vous
voyez que la situation à cet égard là
c'est plutôt amélioré puisque la part
des retraites dans le PIB demain ce
qu'il faudra prélever sur la richesse
produite par les actifs
et moins importante dans nos projections
en 2023 qu'elle ne l'était en 2022
d'accord voilà voilà ce qui a changé
alors comment tout ça s'explique il y a
deux éléments d'explication il y a
effectivement la réforme des retraites
et le changement des données de base et
des projections macroéconomiques de
court terme et les projections
macroéconomiques du court terme elles
ont un effet dans les 50 ans qui
viennent puisque quand on parle d'une
marche plus haute ensuite elle se
prolonge donc c'est en
rouge oranges qu'on a les écarts dues à
la réforme et en vert les écarts du haut
changement des projections économiques
donc je vous ai dit que il y avait un
écart d'environ 0,5 06 et voilà comment
qui s'explique donc ce que vous lisez
sur ce tableau donc en 2022 déjà les
données de base étaient un peu un peu
meilleures puis c'est pour ça qu'on a un
peu de déjà une amélioration sur 2022
en 2030 et bien il y a moins de dépenses
d'Alpine en grande partie c'est lié en
vert à une amélioration de
des prévisions sur ce que sera le PIB en
2030 je vous renvoie ce que je vous ai
dit sur le déflateur et en rouge c'est
l'effet de la réforme donc en 2030 la
réforme
fait baisser la part des dépenses de
retraite vous voyez qu'ensuite en 2050
il y a toujours cet effet PIB cet effet
changement des prévisions
macroéconomiques mais que la réforme des
retraites elle fait plus de dépenses
d'accord alors ça peut sembler paradoxal
mais une réforme des retraites comme le
report de l'âge dans un premier temps ça
fait beaucoup d'économies puisque des
gens qui devaient être à la retraite ne
sont pas à la retraite mais ces gens qui
ne sont pas à la retraite pour certains
ils travaillent et ils acquiert des
droits pendant ce temps qui travaille en
plus du fait de la réforme et donc ils
partent avec des pensions plus élevées
que s'il n'y avait pas eu la réforme
d'accord alors dans un premier temps
l'effet principal c'est le fait qu'on
retient une des gens de partir à la
retraite donc on économise beaucoup mais
progressivement s'accumule dans le stock
des retraités des gens qui sont partis
avec des retraites plus élevées d'accord
donc ça c'est le premier effet par
exemple sur la réforme de 2010 d'accord
ce que l'adresse avait calculée à
l'époque c'est que bout de 20-30 ans les
deux tiers de l'économie avaient été
érodés par l'augmentation de la pension
moyenne et puis dans le cas de la
dernière réforme il y a eu aussi des
mesures sur les basses pensions sur le
micro majoré
beaucoup de débats autour de cette
question mais néanmoins même si il y a
eu des appréciation sur la portée de
cette mesure cette mesure a une portée
sur les basses passions et elle a une
portée qui augmente avec le temps
puisqu'on a maintenant dans notre
système de retraite un élément qui est
indiqué sur les salaires alors qu'avant
dans le système de retraite tout était
indexé sur les prix d'accord donc on
arrive à ce qui pourrait être un
apparent paradoxe mais qui est le
résultat des données c'est que la
réforme des retraites fait baisser la
part des dépenses de retraite en 2030
mais qu'elle augmente
en 2050 et en 2070 et
néanmoins cette augmentation liée à la
réforme à long terme et annuler par le
fait que on a de meilleurs prévisions du
PIB
à court terme
voilà une autre manière d'exprimer ça
sur les effets de la réforme c'est de
voir les effets sur le nombre de
retraités la pension moyenne les
dépenses de retraite c'est la
multiplication du nombre de retraités
multiplié par la pension moyenne et donc
vous voyez qu'en 2030 on a 1,5% de moins
de retraités que s'il n'y avait pas eu
de réformes et qu'on a une augmentation
de la pension moyenne qui en 2030 est
limitée 0,4% parce que les gens qui qui
bénéficient de meilleures patients sont
pas beaucoup dans le stock des retraités
parce que Nico des questions sur les
salaires a pas joué après mais vous
voyez qu'en 2050 on a moins 0,8% de
retraités et on a une pension moyenne
qui est augmentée de 1,5 et donc la
réforme contribue à augmenter les
dépenses et non pas à les diminuer
d'accord
un des paradoxes de cette affaire alors
maintenant je vous ai
je vous ai évoqué
l'effet sur les dépenses voilà quel est
l'effet sur le sur le solde donc là vous
avez un très plein la projection 2023 et
vous avez entrée pointillés la
projection de 2022 et donc on voit bien
que le solde dans un premier temps il
est réduit d'accord
en gros jusqu'aux années 2040 et puis
après alors c'est du hasard mais
complètement
aligné sur ce qu'il était en 2022
d'accord donc dans un premier temps la
réforme des retraites est le changement
des prévisions macroéconomiques fait que
la situation est améliorée sur les
dépenses et sur le solde et puis
qu'ensuite il y a un alignement un
alignement un alignement des courbes je
vais pas
commenter plus avant les écarts sur le
sol puisque je vous ai dit je
n'arriverai pas à distinguer
de la réforme puisque la réforme était
intégrée dans les prévisions de
macroéconomiques en 2022 donc je vous
donne le constat et je ne vous je ne
peux pas aller plus avant dans l'analyse
puisque il faudrait que je que j'ai un
scénario contrefactuel qui aurait été
qu'elles auraient été en 2022 les
prévisions économiques sans la réforme
ce que le trésor n'a pas souhaité n'a
pas pu je ne prononce pas c'est pas les
mettre en cause nous donner et donc on
est dans les spectacle dans les
spectative et dans l'incertitude mais
voilà ce que nous disons cette année
donc tout ça
tout ça
et parfaitement cohérent les membres du
corps ne sont pas des des girouettes qui
changeraient la vie tout ça et
parfaitement documenté sauf les
questions
pendantes que j'ai que j'ai évoquées les
données sont des rapports du corps sont
chaque année
chaque année mise en ligne avec tous les
tableaux Excel Frédéric mortier ribordi
qui qui veille elles sont donc à la
disponibilité je sais bien que personne
ne va lire les tableaux Excel enfin pas
personne il y a des chercheurs qui les
utilisent qui qui les regardent qui les
critiquent et puis le premier qui les
regarde et qu'il critique c'est le
comité de suivi qui est critique pas
beaucoup qui d'ailleurs en général les
conforte c'est le comité des suivis des
retraites qui pour faire son avis et
bien s'appuie sur nos travaux et et les
interroge parce qu'il a des questions
ainsi de suite ce qui permet de
d'assurer la validité mais tout ça par
exemple c'est aussi valider
un dialogue avec la DSS puisque il faut
tout ça correspond pour les 4 ou 5
prochaines années avec ce qu'il vous
diront pour pour le prochain PLFSS donc
voilà
donc voilà ce que je voulais vous dire
sur le
les écarts 2022-2023 que je voulais et
ce que je peux vous dire il y a une
dernière question nous nous sommes à -02
en 2030 avec alors que le gouvernement
avait dit avec votre réforme nous serons
à zéro là clairement moi je ne sais pas
pourquoi je ne sais pas parce que j'ai
vu l'étude d'impact du gouvernement mais
je n'ai pas le sous-jacent de
des calculs qui l'ont amené à dire on
sera on sera à l'équilibre d'accord or
pour comprendre pourquoi nous on est à
-02 et pourquoi le gouvernement disait
on se fera zéro il faudrait qu'on ait le
sous-jacent pour voir faire ce que je
vous ai fait là sur les dépenses des
analyses des cases que ça vienne des
dépenses des ressources de la pension
moyenne du nombre de retraités
franchement je n'ai pas le sous-jacent
voilà donc c'est une question à
expertiser mais c'est plutôt la DSS qui
a nos données et qui a sur certainement
les données de base de des calculs qui
ont servi à affirmation qu'on serait à
l'équilibre en 2030 je viens sur les
ressources et ce sera l'occasion de
d'évoquer la question de du financement
du
régime alors c'est pas un régime du
financement des retraites des
fonctionnaires de l'État alors je parle
de ce tableau qui vous montre les
ressources les ressources du système de
retraite dans sa globalité
il y a certaines ressources dont
personne ne doute que ce sont des
ressources du système de retraite c'est
tout ce qui est en haut c'est les
cotisations des non salariés des
indépendants les cotisations des
salariés et les cotisations employeurs
qui sont affectés à la retraite mais
vous voyez que tout ça ça ne fait qu'en
gros 66% des ressources du système de
retraite le reste
35%, c'est d'autres ressources
et vous en avez la liste et vous voyez
qu'il y a une contribution d'équilibre
43 milliards c'est ce que l'État sous
forme de cotisation fictive alors on
l'appelle contribution contribution
d'équilibre au cotisations fictive verse
effectivement puisque il se verse à
lui-même en gros c'est l'État qui paye
les fonctionnaires et qui paye comment
non mais par ailleurs au total il semble
être mais à la limite le fait le fait
que on affecte fictivement une partie
des ressources de l'État au retraite ne
change pas le bilan global de l'État
d'accord si je n'affecte pas aux
retraites je l'affectue à l'éducation
nationale voilà donc cette opération
d'affecter une partie à travers des
cotisations fictive et une contribution
d'équilibre des ressources aux retraites
des fonctionnaires ne change pas le ne
change pas le déficit du budget de
l'État ou ne change pas le déficit au
niveau de Maastricht d'accord
franchement la Commission européenne ne
tolérerait pas que parce que parce qu'on
fait des cotisations fictives on a un
défilé différentes donc ça ne change
rien simplement une affectation alors
que normalement les ressources de l'État
ne sont pas affectées mais il y a un
compte d'affectation spéciale donc vous
votez chaque année
le montant donc mais vous voyez aussi
par exemple vous avez des impôts et
taxes affectés sur la consommation vous
avez une taxe sur les boissons
alcoolisées qui est affectée au régime
des exploitants agricoles
rien ne justifie cette affectation
personne ne va oser faire un lien entre
la consommation de boissons alcoolisées
et la retraite des exploitants agricoles
en tout cas pas moi ces 3,3 milliards
si 3,3 milliards on pourrait dire bah
c'est une subvention je l'enlève du
régime d'expota agricole dans ce cas-là
elle irait au budget de l'État
ça améliorerait le budget de l'État et
ça dégraderait le compte du régime vous
exploitait agricoles
on peut tout à fait le faire je veux
dire voilà nous au corps on considère
que le législateur dans sa sagesse à
décider d'affecter 3,3 milliards de
taxes sur les boissons alcoolisées ou
les spots agricoles et on ne veut pas
contester cette affectation alors mais
c'est pas sur cette taxe qui a une
contestation c'est sûr cette
contribution d'équilibre d'accord
effectivement
un papier publié dans commentaire succès
de Nîmes de Sophie Bouveret a été repris
par le Commissariat général au Plan par
le Haut Commissariat au Plan
et a dit moi j'enlève sur ces 43
milliards 30 milliards parce que la
cotisation fictive de l'État ça fait une
cotisation salariée employeur à 80%,
alors que dans le privé elle est à 28 %
et donc moi je lève tout ce qui dépasse
28 % et donc ça fait 30 milliards je les
enlève d'accord et donc là d'un coup ça
fait 30 milliards de déficit en plus
d'accord
là aussi alors on peut en discuter ce
que j'avais dit le 19 janvier au fond
pendant des heures d'accord c'est un peu
comme sur ma taxe sur le boisson
alcoolisé voilà mais au corps pour le
moment nous on considère que tant que
les députés votent le compte
d'affectation spéciale dans le cadre de
la loi de finances vote le PLFSS qui
dans
son compte vieillesse puisqu'il y a un
compte de la branche relief dans le
PLFSS reprend
contribution d'équilibre qui nous
appartient pas nous au corps de dire
cette contribution d'équilibre elle est
tendue elle n'a pas de sable c'est ainsi
de suite si demain
les législateur le gouvernement et le
législateur disent attention avant il y
avait une contribution d'équilibre c'est
c'est pas bien il faut plus la faire on
va faire autrement on discute bien
évidemment au corps on en tiendra compte
mais nous on est respectueux de ce qui
voté par
donc la convention du corps c'est ce que
j'essaie d'exprimer là le corps
considère que les ressources du système
de retraite sont celles que le
gouvernement et le législateur
considèrent eux-mêmes être des
ressources du système de retraite et
bien évidemment si change de position on
sera enfin on a discutera enfin je sais
pas ce qui se passera au corps je peux
bon mais voilà et on projette en
postulant que ces décisions
d'affectation seront de même maintenues
mais s'ils sont pas maintenus voilà et
c'est néanmoins on est extrêmement
conscient au corps que c'est une
convention puisque on a au sein de notre
système de retraite une partie des
dépenses de retraite qui sont
automatiquement couvertes par des
ressources donc le calcul de solde à un
caractère extrêmement conventionnel
c'est pour ça que on dit toujours c'est
le solde dans la convention équilibre
permanent des régimes équilibrés ce qui
est une répétition mais pour dire voilà
sachez que quand on calcule le solde on
est obligé d'avoir une convention et
d'ailleurs dans les LFSS et dans la loi
de finance il y a une convention sur les
retraites sur les retraites des
fonctionnaires donc moi
prêt à ouvrir ce débat mais c'est plutôt
dans cette enceinte qui doit avoir lieu
qu'au corps sachez que nous avons nous
recevrons monsieur beaufré qui est des
tenants de cette thèse et Monsieur
Berrou le 21 septembre et donc nous en
parlerons avec les membres du corps mais
on a déjà parlé bien évidemment on n'est
pas on n'est pas hors du monde donc on
sait que il y a un débat vous trouverez
dans le rapport quel est la position
actuelle du corps que je viens d'essayer
de vous de vous de vous reproduire de
j'ai essayé de m'en faire le
porte-parole mais on est parfaitement
enfin je veux dire voilà c'est c'est une
convention qui vous appartient encore
plus que plus qu'à nous voilà
et donc
l'importance de cette convention je vous
ai parlé tout à l'heure de l'évolution
des dépenses et du sol mais le le
chaînon manquant c'est les ressources et
vous voyez là vous avez l'évolution des
ressources en pourcentage du PIB donc
vous voyez que en 2022 on est en
excédent et les dépenses étaient très
faites les ressources c'est très V8
d'accord et vous voyez que ça diminue
alors pourquoi ça diminue si dans notre
système de retraite il n'y avait que des
cotisations
par construction
économique les cotisations elles
évoluent en gros comme le PIB d'accord
puisque elles sont assises sur les
rémunérations et que dans les hypothèses
du corps il y a un partage une stabilité
du partage de la valeur ajoutée entre le
capital et le travail donc ignorer que
des cotisations et bien la courbe là
elle serait complètement droite d'accord
mais je viens de le dire il n'y a pas
que des cotisations et il y a justement
cette contribution de l'équilibre or il
se trouve que les dépenses de retraite
des fonctionnaires vont diminuer dans
l'avenir en pourcentage du PIB et
diminuer de manière sensible parce que
c'est un vieux régime et que c'est un
régime qui arrive au moment où il y a
presque autant de gens qui meurent que
de gens qui arrivent à la retraite il y
a pas eu bon du point d'indiff donc il y
a pas une augmentation importante des
des des
pensions des nouveaux retraités et donc
elle diminue et elle diminue de manière
très sensible donc dans la baisse
qui est là d'accord le fait que les
routes c'est une part des ressources
soit ajustées sur les dépenses la
contribution d'équilibre de l'État et
que ce soit des dépenses qui elles-mêmes
diminuent fait que les ressources du
système de retraite diminuent c'est le
principal facteur sur les 1 4 de
diminution jusqu'à 2070 ça explique 1,2
il y a deux autres facteurs qui
expliquent cette diminution mais qui
sont beaucoup plus mineures c'est le
fait que il y a des ressources qui
viennent
de la Brage famille et de Bénédicte et
comme on prévoit qu'il y aura de même
moins d'enfants et moins de chômeurs et
bien il y a moins de ressources qui
viennent à ce titre là et puis ils se
trouvent que à la scène Racl il y a une
toute cotisation qui est aussi plus
élevée que dans le privé 41% quand on
prend salarié employeur 28% dans le
privé
et la part de la CNRACL du fait des
hypothèses que nous avons sur les
effectifs et sur la rémunération des
agents de la scène raciale va diminuer
et donc ça ça fait 0,1 point de pipe
mais retenez que pour l'essentiel le ce
qui fait baisser les ressources du
système de retraite à l'avenir c'est la
question du régime des fonctionnaires de
l'État et de cette fameuse contribution
d'équilibre voilà
j'en ai terminé avec le propos
un peu le luminaire je sais pas
peut-être que on peut relancer les
questions je sais pas si j'y répondu à
tout je pense à vue nez qu'il faut
avancer sur la suite de la présentation
sauf si il y a des questions tout de
suite
je relance ici
il faut peut-être avoir ta question Eric
peut-être
en général
je pense qu'ils vont
on peut on peut vous avez répondu pas
mal de questions on veut laisser la
parole à partir général à Monsieur
alezette puis après ça vaut pas pour
faire compléter votre peau merci bien
merci Messieurs les Présidents merci
monsieur le Président du corps je suis
ravie qu'on puisse se revoir dans le
cadre de la de cette audition organisée
par La Mecque pour suite à la dixième
parution de du rapport qui constitue un
premier état des lieux de notre système
de retraite postérieur à la réforme du
14 avril dernier mais comme vous le
dites à plusieurs reprises dans votre
rapport ce travail devrait être affiné
pour le rapport pour le prochain compte
tenu des délais courts en fait entre la
réforme et la publication de vos
rapports
avant les quelques questions que j'avais
je souhaiterais vous remercier pour la
qualité de ce rapport qui a répondu à un
certain nombre de questions que nous
avons eu au cours de nos débats
permettre à bord de montrer clairement à
mon sens que la réforme des retraites
était tout autant responsable que juste
en effet vos travaux confirment que la
réforme devrait conduire à plus de
justice sociale car elle permet une
revalorisation des pensions cumulées des
plus modestes jusqu'à 12% pour la
génération née en 84 un certain nombre
d'interrogations subsistent cependant la
lecture de votre rapport au regard à la
fois des hypothèses fournies par le
gouvernement et de celle qui étaient les
vôtres dans celui de 2022 nous estimez
en premier lieu qu'en dépit de la
réforme que nous avons votée le système
de retraite pourrait rester déficitaire
d'environ 7 milliards de roses et 2% du
PIB à l'horizon 2030 la révision de vos
hypothèses macroéconomiques vous conduit
à estimer que indépendamment de la
réforme les recettes comme les dépenses
doivent être diminués de 0,4% ce qui me
semble du coup s'annuler
le gouvernement estime quant à lui que
le système des retraites sera à
l'équilibre en 2030 vous appuyez
pourtant sur les hypothèses du programme
de stabilité 2023 2027 du gouvernement
avait renoncé à l'artefact augmentant
artificiellement le taux de chômage
entre 2027 et 2032 auquel vous aviez
recouru dans votre rapport de septembre
comment expliquer vous alors l'écart de
0,2% qui subsistent
s'agissant toujours des écarts entre
prévisions vous estimez que le système
de retraite était en excédent de 4,4
milliards d'euros en 2022 dans le
rapport de juin 2023 contre un excédent
de 3,2 milliards d'euros dans votre
rapport en septembre 2022 est-ce que
vous pouvez revenir sur cet écart de 1,2
milliards d'euros entre les deux
rapports et concernant les recettes du
système de recettes j'ai de des
retraites j'ai quelques questions la
première porte sur les raisons pour
lesquelles le montant des recettes a
tendance à baisser par rapport à
l'évolution du PIB vous êtes un peu
revenus dans votre présentation mais
cette situation tient selon vous si j'ai
bien compris à trois facteurs la baisse
de la contribution de l'État au régime
spéciaux et régime de la fonction
publique du fait de leur retour
progressif vers l'équilibre de
l'augmentation modérée de la masse
salariale dans la fonction publique en
fin de la diminution du taux de chômage
et donc du financement des dispositifs
de solidarité dans les systèmes de
retraite aussi selon vous pouvons-nous
considérer que ce qui constitue une
baisse de recettes dans le système de
retraite constitue soit une mesure
d'économie pour l'ensemble des
administrations publiques soit un signe
de l'amélioration de la situation de
notre économie et notamment la situation
de l'emploi
ensuite rapidement vous indiquez à
plusieurs endroits du rapport que les
effets de la réforme sur les recettes du
système de retraite sont nuls dans vos
projections en raison de leur
intégration dans les hypothèses du
précédent rapport
il m'est venu deux questions mais une à
laquelle vous avez déjà répondu sur la
part de vos prévisions qui intégraient
une réforme des retraites
conventionnelles et celles qui s'appuie
effectivement uniquement sur la
législation en vigueur ensuite vous
rappelez que compte tenu des délais vous
n'avez pas pu isoler les effets
spécifiques de la réforme ma question
est assez ciblée un article a été adopté
visant à adapter les prélèvements
sociaux sur les indemnités de rupture
dont le produit est affecté à la branche
vieillesse de la sécurité sociale le
produit de ce type de prélèvement a-t-il
été intégré déjà dans vos hypothèses
voilà je vous remercie
merci bien monsieur Erica lezet
merci merci monsieur le Président pour
ce rapport extrêmement précieux j'ai à
titre personnel était toujours
intéressé passionné attentif au rapport
des corps et ceci depuis de nombreuses
années au point que j'avais gardé au fur
et à mesure des rapports une idée assez
générale qui était le fait que si on ne
faisait rien progressivement la pension
des retraités relativement c'est des
actifs et non pas en valeur absolue
diminuerait au minimum de 15% et je
crois en fait que c'est entre 15 et 20%
donc j'avais cette idée là et c'est pour
ça que j'étais un peu déstabilisé par le
rapport 2022 je veux y revenir à mon
tour parce que je pense qu'il
conditionne la suite de des
communications que vous aurez à faire et
et des décisions publiques il a été
évidemment décisif ce rapport dans la
structuration et la formation de
l'opinion publique vous le savez bien
vous avez été haut devant la scène
vous-même à le corps pendant des
semaines et des semaines dans le dans le
débat donc on voit bien que ce que vous
produisez est vraiment structurant
alors effectivement on a beaucoup glosé
sur sur les phrases que vous avez
prononcées je les ai noté moi pour m'en
souvenir les dépenses de retraite sont
globalement stabilisées et même à très
long terme ou encore les dépenses de
retraite ne dérapentent pas elles sont
relativement maîtrisées dans la plupart
des hypothèses alors bien entendu comme
vous l'avez dit à raison pour autant
vous n'avez jamais indiqué qu'il ne
fallait pas faire de réforme bien
entendu et libre à ceux qui veulent
interpréter de de de
le faire et les interprétations ne sont
pas de votre fêtes les données sont
incontestables sont-elles de de votre
fête simplement et permettez-moi de le
dire j'ai eu l'impression que vous
insistiez sur un certain nombre de
données notamment les données de
dépenses en disant qu'elle ne dérapait
pas et peut-être à tort ou à raison les
données sur les recettes ou le sur
l'équilibre sans passer un peu à la
trappe et c'est en cela que que
l'opinion publique s'est structurée
d'une certaine façon et que dans le
débat politique certains de bonne foi
beaucoup de mauvaise foi ont mis la
focale sur
ces seules dépenses d'où la formation de
de l'opinion publique telle que je
l'indiquais et ce qui me semble donc
deux observations à une question pour
conclure que ça je tire deux conclusions
de cela c'est que je crains qu'à l'issue
de cet épisode reste en opinion l'idée
que les avis du corps ne contribuent pas
forcément la bonne prise de décision des
autorités puisque c'est apparu c'est
l'anarchisme entre ce que disait le
corps et et la loi qui a été adoptée
donc je pense qu'il dans l'opinion il
peut rester cette établi là et
la deuxième chose c'est que on a accordé
beaucoup d'écho à ce que vous avez dit
et beaucoup moins la réalité du fond du
du rapport et ma question aujourd'hui
pardon de vous bousculer un peu mais on
est en audition et ce qui si on repart 4
mois en arrière
est-ce que vous seriez pas amené à
prendre un peu plus de précaution dans
la façon dont vous pourriez présenter le
rapport en assistant au moins autant sur
la dynamique des recettes et sur
l'équilibre général que sur les dépenses
merci bien la parole est ta fille Vigier
oui merci monsieur le Président
je vais inscrire mes propos n'allez pas
de ce que bien de prononcé Paris
calausées
on l'aura pas du corps n'a jamais autant
parlé que ces derniers mois et quand
parole est considéré comme d'évangile
naturellement souvent les députés sont
très friands de ce que peut être
expliqué dans tous les rapports qui
sortent donc la question qui vous a été
posée à l'instant de savoir si oui non
vous recriez les mêmes choses dans les
mêmes conditions
chez la prolonge et cela fait bien
également mais
votre tableau il est assez significatif
370 milliards d'euros de dépenses
240 milliards d'euros de recettes de
cotisation où sont les 130 est-ce qu'on
peut continuer à une modélisation dans
laquelle
on part sur un déséquilibre chronique
dont on ne juge pas qu'il faut un moment
le rétablir parce que vous l'avez dit
même d'ailleurs vous mettez même
cotisation fictive le lecteur le quidam
de la rue fictif imaginez l'arme des
destructions massives ça peut
représenter pour lui fictive ne veut
rien dire on cotise on cotise pas je
crois qu'il faut là dessus le clarifier
la deuxième chose allez-vous parce que
on fait des scénarios 2030 à 2050 à 2070
ne sont pas là pour les voir mais
est-ce que vous croyez pas qu'il serait
utile même s'il faut se projeter dans la
durée d'avoir des scénarios beaucoup
plus serrés qui connaît demain le taux
de chômage de 2030 quand on voit qu'on
commande de rentrer dans une récession
qui sait quelles seront naturellement
les taux de croissance des années or les
courbes sur lesquels vous appuyez c'est
pas un procès abdominable si pas
simplement c'est que votre travail et
moi je respecte votre travail a été
l'outil autour de quel
le raisonnement la désinformation ou la
l'information réelle ont été apportées
d'une mission d'évaluation il a dit très
bien où il a mis les pieds dans le plat
et moi je lui en donne acte sur les
petites retraites simplement 40 000
personnes sont concernées nous on veut
faire en sorte que les moins de 1200
euros il y a les 2 millions 4 qui au
terme soit concernés ça serait bien
d'aller productions du corps on voit
quel serait l'effort de la nation qu'il
faudrait faire pour amener ces personnes
à une retraite descente allez-vous
travailler enfin sur des projections
qu'on a entendu dans ce débat
démocratique la retraite à 60 ans à taux
plein pour tout le monde combien ça
coûte quelle est la part des dépenses
publiques comment on la finance quelle
est la sécurisation pour les autres
retraites parce c'est ça le CG si on
doit se projeter il faut avoir tous les
scénarios d'évaluation sinon quelque
part l'image elle est partielle et comme
elle est partielle elle est partielle
elle est pas définition naturellement
est conduit législateur qui ne prend pas
toujours le temps de bien travailler qui
va dire la page 11 de votre rapport la
page 52 qui doivent être je pense au
Guinness des records celles qui ont été
les plus cités pendant l'ensemble du
débat donc vraiment ça me paraît
essentiel que un moment ou un autre sur
tous ces scénarios on se penche bien sur
justement ce déséquilibre structurel que
nous avons dès le départ et qu'il faut
combler
avec le groupe que je représente nous
avions défendu l'idée d'une très heureux
voyeur en 2027 pour voir quelles étaient
d'ailleurs la première fois dans la
forme de retraite où on a fait un bilan
à mes parcours pour savoir si oui ou non
ce que nous pensions était objectif ou
ne l'était pas voilà donc nous dirons
toujours vos rapports une énorme
attention et comme vous propose vous
savez quand président du corps s'exprime
c'était important les médias y apporter
naturellement toute la puissance qu'il
devait y apporter à tout moment donc ça
engage et ça engage souvent et ça
entraîne la présentation nationale et
avec ce moment extrêmement compliqué
qu'on vient de vivre dans le pays
je suis président vous avez la parole
pour répondre à ces nombreuses questions
je suis conscient
que quand je m'exprime ce sera des
effets mesuré mais je suis quand même
obligé de m'exprimer et je ne suis pas
je
peux pas être tenu pour responsable de
toutes les interprétations qui ont été
faites de mes propos franchement
reprenez tous mes propos alors après
vous pouvez dire le temps l'ordre on
reviendra dessus puisqu'on a discuté
avec les membres du corps sur sur
l'ordre de présentation des données mais
voilà donc j'essaie d'être le plus
pédagogique possible et après oui j'ai
noté que certaines disaient le corps dit
qu'il y a un déficit donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut faire une réforme j'ai noté
que certains disaient le corps dit que
les dépenses sont stables et ça veut
dire qu'il faut pas faire dans les
formes mais moi je n'ai jamais dit il
faut faire ou il ne pouvait pas faire de
réforme enfin je donnais moins un acte
ou trouver tout à fait donc voilà bon
après je suis conscient qu'il faut que
je sois le plus prudent possible
j'essaie de l'être
voilà mais mais je peux pas dire en une
phrase tout
tous les attendus d'un rapport qui est
qui en fait qui a fait trois temps la
manière dont on a essayé de répondre un
peu à toutes les questions c'est
de commencer comme ça c'est à dire le
premier tableau que voit les gens dans
la synthèse il y a tout il y a le solde
il y a les dépenses il y a les
ressources c'est ça en gros par rapport
aux questions que vous me posez bien
évidemment je me suis posé moi mais on
se les ai posé avec l'ensemble des
membres du corps et dans une réunion on
a dit pour qu'il n'y ait pas d'ambiguïté
et qu'on puisse pas dire les dépenses
les ressources on met tout dans une
première graphique comme ça celui qui
veut voir et bien il voit tout d'accord
le solde les dépenses et les ressources
et puis après il construit il construit
sa position et ses prises de position
donc je repars sur les questions
entre 0 annoncé par le gouvernement est
-02 annoncé par le corps je vous l'ai
dit moi je ne sais pas pour que je
puisse savoir d'où vient cet écart il
faudrait que j'ai le sous-jacent des
calculs qui ont
servi de base de gouvernement j'ai bien
vu dans l'étude d'impact les résultats
17,7 milliards d'économies mesure
d'accompagnement à hauteur de 5 9 plus
quelques bons voilà donc tout ça j'ai vu
c'est les résultats mais quel était le
sous-jacent quel était le juste une
question
quand vous nous dites je ne sais pas
quel était le sous-jacent du
gouvernement j'imagine que vous le leur
avez demandé parce que le gouvernement
est présent aussi dans le corps c'est à
ce moment donné parce que c'est quand
même un point un peu nodal et pardon
mais ça renvoie aussi à la difficulté
qu'on a pu avoir nous comme
parlementaire de pouvoir connaître
justement les sous-jacents on l'a vu
dans l'étude d'impact quand il est chaud
diffiguré ou que des choses ni
figuraient pas et que donc je trouve que
Philippe si je peux me permettre de
demander au corps d'apporter des
réponses là où il n'a pas les
informations retenues par celui qui
propose une réforme c'est compliqué
d'assigner cette mission cette mission
au corps voilà donc je pose la question
là le quand vous demandez au
gouvernement c'est sous-jacent qu'est-ce
qui vous répond alors
formellement parce que nous notre boulot
notre mission c'est d'établir chaque
année des projections et donc on a les
projections de l'ADN et elle n'est plus
un oncle les écarts voilà c'est Frédéric
qui fait ça parfaitement
et donc on peut faire toutes les
décompositions nous on ne sait pas senti
le gouvernement ne les ayant pas publié
en droit de lui dire on veut faire cette
étude si cette étude doit avoir lieu ben
voilà je veux dire
mais nous les avons pas demandé la
question à la dernière la question que
vous m'avez posée n'a pas été posée lors
de la dernière réunion du corps je
pensais qu'elle allait les lettres ce
que nous avions convenu avec le
directeur de la sécurité sociale c'est
que si cette question est de te poser je
me tournais vers lui et j'aurais été
heureux de savoir ce qui l'aurait
répondu mais comme elle ne lui avait pas
été posée je ne lui je suis pas là pour
mettre en difficulté éventuellement le
directeur de la sécurité sociale donc
voilà de ce que je peux vous dire sur
l'écart 0-02 sur l'écart sur 2022 3,3
milliards 4,4 milliards franchement j'ai
pas le détail de ces 1,2 milliards mais
rendez-vous compte
c'est d'un côté 370 milliards de
dépenses c'est de l'autre côté 370
milliards de ressources au total ça fait
plus de
740 milliards qu'à la fin
il est 1,2 milliard mais je veux dire
c'est l'épaisseur du trait alors si vous
voulez je pense que Frédéric peut peut
vous
pas là
pour la pour lui faire passer un grand
oral elle peut vous donner la
décomposition mais rendez-vous compte
que 1,2 milliards c'est rien quoi
d'accord et ça sur l'année en cours
en plus si on est à 10 ans voilà
sur
sur les trois facteurs qui expliquent la
baisse des
ressources donc voilà donc l'essentiel
c'est la contribution au titre des
fonctionnaires de l'État le reste c'est
presque négligeable d'accord simplement
pour boucler les opérations que le
mention c'est ça
et j'en profite pour revenir sur la
convention et fort de l'État constant
voilà puisque dans le dernier rapport
nous présentions les résultats du régime
avec deux conventions EPR et
la convention est fort de l'État
constant c'était de gommer cet effet
baisse de la contribution d'équilibre en
disant l'état maintient sa contribution
au système de retraite même si la moins
la payer pour ses fonctionnaires
d'accord c'était pour montrer ça voulait
être pédagogique comment le déficit
s'expliquer en grande partie par cette
baisse des ressources nous avons
et nous avons considéré au corps depuis
que ce que nous pensions être
pédagogique ne l'était pas et
embrouiller les choses et si vous vous
référez à mon audition du 19 janvier
j'avais moi-même pris la liberté
vis-à-vis des membres du corps
d'anticiper et je ne vous ai parlé de 19
janvier que dans la convention EPM il en
avait pas évoqué la couverture aussi la
convention aussi c'est un moyen
pédagogique de dire bon pourquoi alors
qu'on dit que les dépenses sont stables
il y a un déficit c'est parce que les
ressources baissent les ressources
baisse à cause de la contribution
d'équilibre donc on vous montre qu'il y
a moins de déficits quand on se
stabilise la contribution de l'État
voilà bon on s'est aperçu que certains
nous accusez au corps de préambet des
économies futures de l'État en les
affectant au système de retraite alors
que bien évidemment c'est le législateur
qui décidera si ces économies il faut
les affecter à l'éducation nationale la
santé à la défense à la justice et la
donc franchement au corps on se prend
pas la dent on ne se substitue pas au
législateur on a vu que ça pouvait être
cette lecture de la convention aussi et
donc cette année les membres du corps
ont décidé de de la mettre à l'annexe
pour pouvoir faire un suivi historique
des choses mais on ne l'utilise plus
voilà voilà mon année sur sur ces
recettes sur les effets
spécifiques des indemnités de rupture
voilà
il faut il faut que tu quand il y a des
recettes liées à des événements il faut
qu'on ait des hypothèses sur la nature
de ces vêtements donc cette année on les
a pas intégré
alors sur sur la baisse de la pension
relative écoutez
on essaie chaque année d'y insister
parce que bien souvent quand je dis les
dépenses de retraite sont stables ça
suscite un étonnement parmi ceux qui
n'ont pas lu le rapport du corps parce
que ce qui est évident
et massif c'est que la France vieillit
et que donc demain il y aura plus de
retraités par rapport aux actifs
vous l'avez sur cette courbe on est à un
de cette cotisants par retraité et on
sera un 4 degrés cette courbe c'est un
classique des rapports du corps mais on
met un regard une autre évolution qui
est la baisse de la pension relative et
cette baisse de la peinture relative
elle est moindre après la réforme des
retraites que ce qu'elle était avant
puisque ça augmente les pensions
moyennes et il se trouve que c'est la
résultante de ces deux forces qui fait
que les pensions le niveau des pensions
par rapport aux pub malgré le
vieillissement de la population qui est
évident inéluctable et rappelé dans tous
les rapports du corps en introduction et
bien il y a une stabilisation une
stabilisation des pensions donc cette
année par exemple dans la synthèse on
dit oui les dépenses sont stables mais
ça deux revers le premier revers c'est
que ça risque de se traduire par
une diminution du niveau de vie de
retraité par rapport à l'ensemble de la
population c'est la courbe que nous
publions d'habitude actuellement les
retraités au niveau de vie supérieur à
celui de l'ensemble de la population et
ça même sans compter les loyers imputés
et vous voyez que mécaniquement et bien
alors qu'on est à plus de sens ça ira à
87 dans 87 et 75 et dans l'hypothèse
d'orange on doit être autour de 85
attention ça c'est une projection
mécanique parce que si les Français les
assurés ne sont très défavorables à
cette évolution et considère que ils
n'ont pas assez à la retraite ils
peuvent réagir de deux manières soit en
épargnant plus pendant leur vie active
alors ils peuvent réagir encore faut-il
qu'il le puissent vraiment d'accord tout
le monde ne peut pas épargner plus
pendant sa vie active mais ça c'est à
comportement d'épargne et de départ à la
retraite constant d'accord donc ils
peuvent réagir de deux manières soit un
épargnant plus pendant leur vie active
pour
vital pendant la retraite soit
en repoussant au-delà même de ce qui est
exigé par la réforme leur départ pour le
moment les Français partent en très
grande majorité au taux plein
qui partent un peu avant quelques-uns
qui partent un peu après on peut
imaginer que si certaines assurés ne
sont pas satisfaits de leur niveau de
vie
à la retraite
par rapport à ce niveau de vie couronne
de main les actifs il décide eux-mêmes
de repousser il y a actuellement 12 à
13% des gens qui surcôtent donc on peut
pour imaginer que dans cette
mécaniquement ça a cet effet là et on
insiste beaucoup sur le fait que bien
évidemment on peut pas avoir le beurre
et l'argent du beurre et que si des
dépenses de retraite se stabilisent
c'est parce qu'il y a cette éventualité
d'une baisse du niveau de vie relatif on
insiste aussi sur le fait que le
vieillissement de la population il est
son effet sur le système de retraite et
ralentit par le recul de l'âge là vous
avez un pointillé
ce qu'aurait été là sans la réforme vous
avez entrée plein ce qui est l'âge
maintenant l'âge de départ maintenant
qui a eu lieu la réforme vous voyez que
ça fait un décalage d'environ 6 mois
et ça veut dire que la durée de retraite
va elle-même diminuer donc en gros pour
ce qui est de la durée de retraite on a
atteint un pic pour la génération 1950
celle qui est partie juste avant à 60
ans la réforme de
2010 qui a repoussé l'âge de 64 62 ans
voyez ensuite une une diminution du
temps passé à la retraite
en pointillés c'était ceux qui avaient
avant de la réforme donc ça se
stabilisait et puis là on voit que ça
continue à diminuer et on ne retrouvera
le la durée de retraite Capu que devrait
connaître la génération 1950 que dans
les générations 1990 d'accord donc la
stabilisation
des dépenses de retraite dans le PIB à
deux revers
une éventualité d'une baisse du niveau
de vie relatif des retraités par rapport
aux actifs et une diminution de la durée
de la durée de retraite
alors est-ce qu'il faut prendre plus de
précautions dans notre dans notre
expression
bien évidemment on en a discuté donc
chaque année au corps en avril on fait
une réunion pour préparer le rapport de
jeu d'accord et notamment sur cette
question de l'ordre dans lequel on
présente les données d'accord l'ordre
classique
c'était
j'explique ce qui se passe sur les
dépenses j'explique ce qui se passe sur
les ressources et le résultat c'est le
solde d'accord je vous avoue que moi
c'est l'ordre qui me paraît le plus
pédagogique pour que les gens
comprennent d'accord et moi j'ai plutôt
toujours depuis que je suis encore
défendu cet ordre donc on parle des
dépenses des ressources et on donne le
résultat le solde on a eu ce débat
certaines 10 ans il faut parler du solde
au début
on voit bien que si on parle du sol de
début ça n'est plus intention et c'est
plutôt favorable à répondre je comprends
tout ça
il y a des gens encore qui disent il
faut parler du centre de début quel est
le compromis auquel nous sommes parvenus
dans cette réunion d'avril
qui est dû à un membre du Parlement qui
est au corps
c'est
c'est oui on continue la même pédagogie
d'accord on parle des dépenses des
ressources et du solde parce que c'est
la bonne manière d'être pédagogue et de
faire comprendre et puis c'est aussi
parce que la chose la plus tangible dans
tout ce que je vous dis c'est des
dépenses de retraite par rapport au bip
pourquoi parce que sur les ressources
vous l'avez vu c'est un truc qui est
bourré de convention et là on vient de
me dire que le déficit il est pas de de
0 mais qu'il est de 30 milliards et puis
il en rajouter 114 milliards de voilà
donc les ressources c'est hyper
conventionnel donc
parlons de la chose la plus tangible qui
est les départs parce que sur les
dépenses de retraite quand je dis ça
c'est des dépenses de retraite à peu
près tout le monde est d'accord sur ce
que j'ai mis dans les dépenses de
retraite le Bible tout le monde est
d'accord sur ce qu'est le pipe mais dès
que je parle des ressources vous voyez
qu'il y a des débats bon donc les
membres du corps ont validé
donc c'est pas voilà on a la discuté et
tout le monde n'était pas d'accord je
vais pas vous dire que voilà je vous
donnerai pas les normes mais voilà
on valider l'ordre de présentation
dépense ressources et soldes mais c'est
pour ça que ça vient insisté dès le
début de ma présentation
on dit mais pour qu'il n'y ait pas
d'ambiguïté on commence par un premier
tableau qui présente tout d'un coup
d'accord donc celui qui veut
celui qui veut faire le solde il cache
ce qu'il y a à droite et puis regarde
qu'à gauche d'accord celui qui veut
parler des dépenses il cache qui a bon
mais franchement
je pense que c'est mieux dans la
présentation mais quelque soit la
manière dont je m'exprime quel que soit
la manière dont je présente les choses
je tiens
les
participants se débat sont suffisamment
malins pour même si je parle des
dépenses en deuxième pour mettre des
vergues les dépenses pour ceux qui sont
opposés à la réforme et si je parle des
du soldat 2e ceux qui sont favorables à
la réforme sont suffisamment malins pour
pour mettre un exemple le sol donc je
veux bien franchement je vais essayer de
faire tout ce que je peux pour être le
plus neutre possible mais je voilà j'ai
aussi mes limites alors sur
sur monsieur Vigier donc il a réagi à ce
à ce tableau mais ce tableau donc il est
dans ce rapport mais il était dans les
précédents donc le corps n'a jamais
caché et c'est pour ça qu'il parlait de
convention que il y avait une grande
partie des ressources du système de
retraite qui n'étaient pas des
cotisations au sens stricte vraiment
prélevé sur les actifs ou sur sur les
salaires donc voilà il y a une grande
partie
si vous retirez toutes les autres
ressources si vous retirez 35% des
ressources vous avez un déficit énorme
mais attention
c'est à vous de définir ces conventions
parce que toutes ces affectations vous
les valider dans les textes mais si vous
ne les validez pas si vous dites demain
le déficit il est 214 milliards
je vous invite à prendre garde parce
qu'après les conséquences qui font en
tirer en matière de retraite vous avez
vu le débat que nous avons eu alors que
il s'agissait de régler un déficits de
12 milliards si j'arrive régler un
déficit de 114 milliards
à 80 ans de la cage de départ si je peux
me permettre dans ces sommes il y a les
cotisations des fonctionnaires il y a
les compensations des mesures
qui ont été prises ça ça peut est-ce
qu'on peut est-ce qu'on peut mieux le
préciser et puis après effectivement il
y a effectivement le financement des
retraites par le biais d'État est-ce
qu'on pourrait mieux définir à votre
avis ces trois choses qui sont et la
retraite des fonctionnaires et les
compensations et une subvention
d'équilibre mais alors la subvention
d'équilibre là quand je mets subvention
d'équilibre c'est toutes les cotisations
fictives des employeurs par exemple
le le
Commissariat au Plan il n'enlève pas les
43 milliards
il enlève 30 milliards sur ses 43 et sur
les 7,3 qui sont en dessous il enlève 30
à peu près
quel est son raisonnement c'est si je
prends les cotisations
au titre des fonctionnaires de l'État
fictif tout ça qui font de la situation
d'équilibre on est à 80% alors que dans
le privé on est à 28 alignons sur 28
donc il enlève pas tous mais j'enlève
une partie mais nous
alors ça fait des années que dans le
corps c'est un rituel il y a cette étude
du chaque année bien évidemment quand on
voit un taux de 80% d'un taux de 28 on
s'est interrogé et on s'est dit mais
pourquoi pourquoi il y a un tel écart et
est-ce que ça renvoie à des avantages
particuliers des fonctionnaires donc
vous avez dans le rapport du corps je
crois que c'est la page 100 on dit d'une
part les assiettes sont pas les mêmes
pour les fonctionnaires la cotisation
n'est que sur le traitement indiciaire
hors prime alors que dans le privé elle
est surtout le sur tout le traitement
situation démographique sont extrêmement
différentes d'accord le régime ne
fonctionnaires il y a plus de retraités
qu'il n'y a de
cotisante qui n'est pas le cas dans le
régime du privé d'accord ensuite le
financement de la solidarité est
extrêmement différent dans le privé vous
avez le FFV avec des ressources qui ne
sont pas des cotisations qui vient
prendre en charge certaines dépenses de
solidarité il n'y a aucune dépense de
solidarité pris dans les fonctionnaires
pour les pour le régime les
fonctionnaires dans le régime des
fonctionnaires vous avez un dispositif
de solidarité qui est relativement
coûteux c'est les catégories actives qui
concernent
notamment les policiers catégories
principales les gardiens de prison
les policiers en France ils ne protègent
pas que les fonctionnaires il protège
l'ensemble de la population en tout cas
c'est ce que j'espère si donc il faut
marquer
un effort particulier pour cette
profession ça n'a pas à être prise en
charge par le régime strictement des
fonctionnaires d'accord ça c'est voilà
bon donc quand on gomme tous ces effets
vous avez les résultats dans le truc du
corps on aboutit à des taux de
cotisation relativement homogène bon
maintenant mais là à nouveau donc là
j'engage la discussion au fond sur cette
question et puis par ailleurs quand on
se dit est-ce qu'il y a des avantages
indues des fonctionnaires donc l'adresse
fait régulièrement une étude que nous
publions elle prend les carrières des
fonctionnaires et puis elle leur
applique les règles du régime général
des Arco Agirc et elle liquide leur
retraite comme s'ils avaient été au
régime général et Harco agir et on
s'aperçoit que en moyenne c'est à peu
près équivalent d'accord et qui a des
fonctionnaires qui gagnent à passer
arcoag enfin effectivement au régime
général erquelin donc
moi je suis assez réticent par rapport à
cette convention qu'elle lèverait d'être
milliards mais on va avoir le débat mais
à nouveau le débat on l'aura au corps
moi je suis prêt à alimenter ceux qui
veulent travailler sur cette question
mais après c'est franchement c'est
c'est vous qui c'est vous qui déciderez
si si lors du prochain PLFSS il y a des
députés qui disent nous on veut plus
voter un PLFSS avec une subvention
d'équilibre du régime des fonctionnaires
le corps se dira des choses ont changé
dans la manière dont on a une
rendez-vous compte
donc vous avez 43 milliards de
subventions d'équilibre vous devez avoir
une dizaine de milliards de cotisations
des fonctionnaires directs d'accord donc
en gros les dépenses de retraite des
fonctionnaires c'est 53 milliards vous
enlevez 30 milliards mais après une fois
que vous avez fait ça quelle décision
vous prenez sur la retraite des
fonctionnaires parce que une fois que
vous avez enlevé 50% des ressources du
régime des fonctionnaires soit vous
dites aux fonctionnaires faut passer à
80 ans soit vous dites faut diminuer les
pensions de moitié
c'est intéressant c'est une analyse
d'avoir un budget plus analytique je
légitime dans ces sommes il y a le le
l'État en tant qu'employeur est-ce qu'on
peut
analytique le calculer il y a toutes les
il y a toutes les compensations il y a
toutes les compensations des mesures qui
sont prises par l'État et puis après
effectivement il y a une subvention
d'équilibre est-ce qu'on pourrait avoir
une meilleure analyse il s'agit pas
d'enlever il s'agit de mieux analyser
pour savoir effectivement entre
guillemets quel est le déficit de des
retraites que le le l'État finance c'est
ça c'est quelque chose de plus
analytique
pour ce qui est de l'État la subvention
d'équilibre ou les cotisations fictives
versées par l'État lui-même dans le code
c'est 43 milliards voilà les subventions
les subventions d'équilibre qui verse au
régime spéciaux donc il assure
l'équilibre la RATP ainsi de suite c'est
7,3 milliards et puis après vous avez
tout le reste donc mais après on peut
bien évidemment raffiner donc mais mais
posez-nous les questions nous enfin je
veux dire dans la mesure du possible on
répondra à tout parce que là
effectivement c'est encore un tableau
agrégé mais on a le tableau avec tous
les détails
parce qu'il nous reste à peine 10
minutes je viens quand même un point sur
lequel je voudrais qu'on revienne parce
qu'il s'est un des apports du rapport
qui nous avait fait je le dis défaut au
moment du vote de la loi sur un certain
nombre d'éléments parce que ça ne figure
pas dans l'étude d'impact et qu'il a
fallu aussi aller à la pêche aux
informations vous le savez bien c'est
sur les effets redistributifs de la
réforme
puisque vous avez versé des études que
l'adresse elle-même avait pu faire par
la suite à partir de génération type
1972 celle là c'est la mienne 1984
c'est pour ça que vous l'avez fait 72
bah c'est j'avais interpellé le Ministre
justement parce que c'était la
génération bascule
alors sur les effets
redistributif vous dites que la réforme
conduit à un report de l'âge de départ
plus important pour les femmes pour les
personnes ayant de faibles pensions et
pour les personnes hors de l'emploi
avant la retraite donc mais en même
temps les les durées
sont pas très significatives en fait sur
le le différentiel mais je veux bien
qu'on s'arrête un peu là dessus puis il
y a l'eau de volley qui est sur l'impact
de la réforme sur l'équité entre les
générations donc vous nous dites qu'elle
serait qu'elle serait très limitée
est-ce qu'on peut juste revenir en gros
est-ce que dans la suite des rapports du
corps vous pourrez affiner ces éléments
là sur la dimension redistributive et
sur l'impact en termes d'équité de la
réforme
on est à l'écoute des questions que vous
pourriez nous transmettre mais vous
voilà un peu le donc effectivement on a
demandé cette étude à l'adresse
puisque comme je vous l'ai dit une
réforme qui repousse l'âge elle l'oblige
déjà à retarder l'arrache de départ mais
se traduit par une augmentation de la
pension moyenne et une manière d'avoir
une synthèse de ça c'est de regarder la
pension cumulée sur le cycle de vie
d'accord c'est à dire combien je vais
toucher moins longtemps mais je vais
toucher plus et bien combien je touche
au total sur mon cycle de vie on a de
l'hypothèses sur sur l'espérance de vie
à la retraite et donc voilà les voilà
les résultats pour la variation de l'âge
de départ vous voyez que donc c'est
exprimé à moi donc pour la génération de
66 et 7 mois à peu près 6,9 mois et pour
la génération 84 c'est 6 mois parce que
la génération 84 déjà elle partait plus
tard que la génération 66 elle est donc
un peu moins d'impacter pour la
variation de la pension à liquidation
vous voyez que pour la génération 66 ça
augmente de 1,2 et pour la génération 84
de 2 notamment parce que la mesure miko
et l'indexation sur les salaires et
cumulatif et donc je vous rappelle pour
cette génération et donc vous avez le
résultat en synthèse qui est la
variation de la pension cumulée sur le
cycle de vie et vous voyez que pour la
génération de 66 c'est pour ça qu'il y a
des économies en 2030 c'est moins pour
cent et pour la génération 84 c'est plus
c'est 09 c'est pour ça que je vous
disais tout à l'heure à terme la réforme
des retraites
crée plutôt des dépenses alors ça c'est
toute la population confondue alors je
mentiais maintenant à la variation de la
pension cumulée mais vous avez tous les
détails en annexe de du rapport du corps
vous avez l'étude complète vous pouvez
tout tout regarder et donc là vous donne
simplement les les trois générations en
distinguant homme femme les femmes sont
violées les hommes sont en rouge donc on
voit que pour la peinture cumulée
en 60 pour la génération 66 les hommes
sont plus pénalisés que les femmes au
regard de ces critères pensions cumulés
et qu'en 80 4 les femmes sont plus
favorisées on regarde des critères
pensions cumulés que que les hommes et
puis on l'a fait aussi
par quartile de niveau de pension et
là on voit que c'est le quartile qui a
les pensions les plus faibles qui
gagnent le plus en pension cumulée
notamment à la génération 84 parce que
l'effet cumulatif d'une indexation du
micro majoré
joue à plein et on voit que ceux qui
perdent c'est plutôt les niveaux de de
pension des des deux derniers quartiers
parmi les plus aisés des retraités donc
la franchement je simplifie la richesse
de l'étude de l'adresse
bon il y a plein de prolongements qu'on
peut faire une des une des limites parce
que c'est indicateur de pension cumulée
l'intérêt d'agréger le fait que je
retarde mon départ mais je touche plus
donc là j'ai une mesure agrégée de tout
ça mais bien évidemment
l'essentiel dans une réforme des
retraites c'est
vous allez gagner plus mais vous allez
avoir du temps disponible à moins
d'accord or pour mesurer l'effet sur le
bien-être
pour certains gagner plus c'est bien
parce que ils n'ont pas envie d'être la
retraite et il s'ennuient ils n'ont pas
envie d'aller à la pêche ou de s'occuper
de leur petit enfant donc parfait mais
vous en avez vous avez d'autres
personnes et je porte aucun jugement
moral je veux dire qui
préfère s'occuper de leur petit enfant
ou aller à la pêche et franchement la
pêche c'est pas mon kiff comme dirait
mon ado mais je suis parfaitement
respectueux de ceux qui veulent aller à
la pêche et donc pour certains voilà
donc là on agrège en pension cumulée
donc en richesse mais ça ne dit pas
c'est qu'à ça quand même impact sur le
bien-être ressenti des gens parce que
les gens qui aspirent à être libérés de
leur travail même si ils gagnent plus
peut-être que on dégrade leur bien-être
voilà pour ceux qui leur travail est
assez ils vont continuer un peu ils vont
gagner plus tout ça tout ça est parfait
vous avez des prolongements qui
pourraient être faites c'est de regarder
les revenus totaux sur la vie active
puisque là on prend pas leur compte le
fait que celui qui repousse son âge de
la retraite pendant qu'il est au travail
s'il est au travail et bien il va gagner
plus que ce qu'il était à la retraite on
ne fait que la pension cumulée sur le
cycle de vie donc on peut raffiner ces
études
on peut on peut les approfondir et
franchement si vous avez
des questions des des pistes
on peut avec des administrations puisque
là on s'appuie sur l'adresse essayer de
répondre à vos interrogations mais on a
on a tenu à donner un premier un premier
élément d'appréciation
non non
on a pris alors
l'adresse quand on lui pose la question
on dit que ça pourrait être mieux fait
non c'est pas mieux donc l'adresse
reconnaît que ça pourrait être mieux
fait mais elle a pris des des espérances
de vie différenciées selon le niveau de
la pension puisqu'on sait que les
espérances de vie sont différenciées
selon le niveau de la pension voilà mais
bon c'est ici que vous dit toujours
qu'il pourrait mieux faire mais enfin
ils vont commencer à l'intégrer parce
que sinon effectivement c'est bien les
résultats
très bien
en vous remerciant on a tenu l'horaire
alors moi ce que je vous propose parce
qu'il y a encore quelques points qu'on
n'a pas abordé notamment
mais vous viendrez nous en parler la
question sur l'évolution des droits
familiaux de retraite sur lequel travail
est lancé mais ça nous dit une chose
nous on aura très plaisir à accueillir
le président du corps pour la
présentation du prochain rapport donc en
septembre en septembre prochain donc
rendez-vous est pris pas forcément à la
messe moi je le souhaite mais je le dis
devant la rapporteur comme c'est la
tradition dans le cadre de la commission
des affaires sociales pour aborder
l'ensemble de ces sujets et au moment de
n'abordera la branche vieillesse et là
le rapporteur prendra sa casquette et
aussi parce que je le redis voilà on a
besoin on a besoin de ces éclairages
fournis par le corps nonobstant les
poussées du urticaire qui peut
déclencher ici ou là voilà